CONDITION.
SHE REPORTEDLY WAS UPSET OVER
YOUTUBE POLICY, SHE SAID WERE
SUPPRESSING SOME OF HER VIDEOS.
IN A LITTLE LESS THAN AN HOUR,
BELLS WILL TOLL, FIRST IN
MEMPHIS AND THEN AROUND THE
WORLD TO MARK THE 50TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ASSASSINATION
OF MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.
CORRESPONDENT JONATHAN SERRIE
REPORTS ON THE OBSERVANCES FROM
MEMPHIS.
>> THOUSANDS GATHERED IN MEMPHIS
TO COMMEMORATE THE 50TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ASSASSINATION
OF DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.
>> WHEN I WAS 16 YEARS OF AGE,
THAT MAN TOUCHED MY LIFE AND
DIRECTED MY PATH.
TODAY, I AM EXHILARATING VOICES
OF YOUNG PEOPLE AROUND THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, WHO
ARE AGAIN USING THE SAME THING
THAT I FELT.
>> ON APRIL 3RD, 1968, KING AND
HIS ENTOURAGE CAME TO MEMPHIS TO
SUPPORT STRIKING SANITATION
WORKERS.
HE RALLIED THEM WITH HIS "I'VE
BEEN TO THE MOUNTAINTOP" SPEECH.
THE FOLLOWING EVENING, THE CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADER AND FORMER U.N.
AMBASSADOR ANDREW YOUNG
REMEMBERS JOKING AROUND WITH
KING BACK AT THE MOTEL.
>> I SAID SOMETHING SMART AND HE
PICKED UP A PILL AND THREW IT AT
ME.
AND I THREW IT BACK AND THEN
EVERYBODY PICKED UP PILLOWS AND
STARTED BEATING ME UP.
AND IT WAS LIKE, THIS IS THE
HAPPIEST MOMENT I HAD SEEN.
>> MOMENTS LATER, KING STEPPED
ONTO THE BALCONY OUTSIDE ROOM
306 OF THE LORRAINE MOTEL WHEN A
SHOT FIRED FROM A WINDOW OF A
BOARDINGHOUSE ACROSS THE STREET
TO.
>> SAW HIS SHOES STUCK IN THE
GREAT AND I RAN UP THE STEPS AND
REALIZED THAT HE HAD BEEN SHOT
AND THAT HE WAS LAYING THERE IN
A PUDDLE OF BLOOD.
>> THE SITE OF KING'S
ASSASSINATION IS NOT PRESERVED
AS PART OF THE NATIONAL CIVIL
RIGHTS MUSEUM.
>> HE CAPTURED THE HUMAN
PREDICAMENT IN A WAY THAT FEW
ARE ABLE TO CAPTURE.
>> KING'S YOUNGEST DAUGHTER,
BERNICE, TO WORD A NEW EXHIBIT
HONORING HER FATHER'S LIFE.
AS OF MONDAY, SHE COMES TO THIS
PLACE NOT JUST TO REMEMBER WHAT
HAPPENED HALF A CENTURY AGO,
BUT TO CELEBRATE THE ENDURING
IMPACT KING CONTINUES TO HAVE ON
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
>> HE LEFT US WITH A BLUEPRINT
FOR MOVING FORWARD.
>> CHRIS, THE NATIONAL CIVIL
RIGHTS MUSEUM IS GOING TO MARK
THE MOMENT KING WAS
ASSASSINATED, 6:01:00 P.M.
CENTRAL TIME, BY RINGING A BELL
AND THEN ENTER GO MINUTE
INCREMENTS, BELLS WILL BEGIN TO
TOLL THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF
MEMPHIS AND THEN NATIONALLY AND
THEN AROUND THE WORLD.